there are lots of ways to think and what
you want is you want a toolkit of ways
to think and you want ways to think to
be aligned with the problems you're
thinking about so we talked about sort
of four examples of ways of thinking
there's engineering thinking which is
very prevalent in modern society because
of our technical society and engineers
solve same problems to which there are
clear repeatable solutions once I figure
out how to build the Brooklyn Bridge I
can build it again and again it'll work
every time
that's a taint that's a hard problem but
it's the same problems well-behaved
it'll lack tomorrow just like it acted
today business problems you use
optimization thinking there's no right
answer to your branding no right answer
to your market share but you can
optimize and that's a different kind of
thinking researchers do analytic
thinking if you start with the premise
they thin slice it down they've got a
questioning process those are ways of
thinking what we call wicked problems
that's a technical term developed by
some urban planners at Berkeley back in
the 70s a wicked problem is one where
the criteria for success are unclear
constantly changing you won't know you
got the right answer until you find it
and once you've found it you can't reuse
it again you can't rebuild New York City
somewhere else you can't be Dave Evans
again you can't be somebody else again
so wicked problems are inherently human
problems and they're messy problems and
they're trying to intersect a future
that none of us knows enough about so so
how do you do that you can't analyze
that so you build your way for it in
design we build our way forward and we
build our way forward by sneaking up on
the future through this iteration of
prototypes get curious ask a question
understand it try something learn
something do it again do it again till
you get enough of an idea that you can
implement and actually solve a problem
okay we have two kinds of prototyping
engineering prototypes and design
prototypes now if I should also clarify
every time I say the word design here I
mean design is in designed thinking or
technically human centered design the
design program at Stanford was formed in
the 60s it's over 54 years old it's the
eldest interdisciplinary program at the
University the marriage of art human
factors and mechanical engineering is
actually located in the ME Department so
where we technically work
and that design was conceived as an
innovation methodology not as craft most
designers in the world were trained in
the craft of design graphic designers
can draw and lay things out and
industrial designers can shape things
even ergonomic designers can shape
things in a particular kind of a way
Stanford designers do design thinking
and design thinking as a methodology
it's not reliant upon craft and it's
highly transferrable so when I talk
about a design prototype I mean a design
thinking prototype Engineers prototype
things to prove that that tames solution
to that tame problem they figured out
does in fact work correctly so if I'm
going to I actually have a master's in
thermo Sciences haven't used it much but
there you go used to know how to
calculate a flame speed and design a
turbine engine so if I'm going to design
a turbine engine I'm General Electric
I'm going to run prototypes you know in
a big soundproof cinder block
you know boxed so when it blows up
people don't get hurt and prototype one
and prototype 2 and prototype 3 are
different variations on the turbine
blades on this big fan that spins a
hundred thousand rpm and we're going to
make sure that it works under stress
conditions and if it breaks we're going
to make a modification we're going to
get that engineering done right that's
engineering prototyping to prove that
the idea I had works correctly because I
think I know what the answer is a design
prototype is not to prove my end
solution right it's to find out what I
want to do in the first place so an
engineering prototype starts with a
conclusion a design prototype starts
with a curiosity so when we do
prototyping a design like what do I want
to know more about well I can't even
think about that or I could try it so
this is the empirical embodied
experience of going out and trying
things so for instance when I was
prototyping the mutt when I was the
first mouse product manager at Apple
many many years ago we prototype the
mass now the mouse was across an
electromechanical device it had this
little ball and it had you know
trigger LED detectors in it there were
brand new technology and those things
could be engineering prototyped but
whether or not you liked the way it felt
in your hand or rolling this thing
around on the desk and then looking at
the screen over there made sense to you
we had no idea how that was going to go
we had hundreds of proto one button or
two
I had long and religiously IDIA
logically animated conversations with
Larry Tesler and Steve Jobs about one
button or two and mode lessness and
double clicking and you know there's no
answer to those questions to try them so
we did lots and lots of prototypes of
process or experience and lots of
prototypes of shape and what happened we
ended up with the mouse and the mini
mice we have today couldn't have
engineered that we had to design that we
want an example of a life prototype so
there's a woman we know actually an
example who didn't do much prototyping
you know we'll call her Ellen and she
was an HR executive but loved Italian
food and it always dreamed of having an
Italian deli and she decided to go for
it so she went for it so she saw this
old deli it was for sale she bought it
she quit her job she refurbished the
whole thing she redesigned it she laid
it out she put in a little cafe because
she wanted to replicate this experience
she'd had living in Tuscany briefly and
it opened a great fanfare and was
wonderfully successful
nobody's successful the first time at a
restaurant never happens except she
hated it she loved the idea of it she
loved developing it and I'm running a
retail establishment I have to hire
people all the time most of my employees
are high school kids and they quit on
you're regularly managing inventory
lists none of the reality of running an
Italian deli and cafe was really
delightful to her now the prototypes
that she could have iterate she could
have started with visiting a lot of
different Italian cafes and talking to
the owner she could have gotten a job as
a bus girl actually waiting on tables
you know enough to be a waiter because
they're sort of be trained but I can
clear the tables and overhear the
conversations and see if people are
having as good a time as I think they
will in my place I could try catering on
a weekend I could cater my friend's
daughter's wedding that's not a very big
commitment no capital is out laid do I
really want to cook that much lots of
ways to try try try try try before you
jump off the cliff oh by the farm and
that will give you feedback about what
the reality really is what prototypes
InDesign do are they allow you to ask
interesting questions learn things
expose your assumptions and let you
sneak up on the future so prototyping is
a great way to go for your life because
nobody knows the answer